one of the reasons why I loved getting
stone is I was so good at making things
so did you have that crisis when you
were newly sober of like I'm never going
to be able to do anything creative again
no because it's just I was in the storm
I didn't have a choice there was like no
other way for me to make a living it's
like there's this scene in uh hearts of
Darkness it's about the making of
Apocalypse Now and Francis Ford Coppola
who's like 35 years old and he's like
mortgaged his house and everything to
pay for this production in the monsoon
has wiped out the stat and the studio
stopped giving him money he's like how
can I quit I can't quit he's like I
could put a bullet in my head and I mean
that's what it comes down to there is no
case
it's worse and this is what you know sax
told me this sax is like you know when
you're starting the first thing you do
when you make a little money spend every
penny so that you have to keep going